the motion capture stuff that ended up
being really easy
all the stuff that we thought was gonna
be easy ended up being the hardest part
good ideas take a lot of work
that laugh was kind of just me
reflecting on
look guys myself and wren are currently
working
on the most difficult challenging most
technically involved
shot that corridor digital has ever seen
i mean confirm it with sam confirm with
nico
i absolutely confirm and i take 100 of
the responsibility for all the pain that
you feel
we're working on the hardest shot that
quarter digital has ever seen not only
is there one
there's six of these shots would you say
this is someone's fault could
could you would you blame me for this
because i'm trying to figure out if i
should feel bad or not
i blame nobody okay blame nobody i blame
the good idea being so good that we just
had to do it
good ideas take a lot of work you guys
have seen those boston dynamics videos
where there's like that
mechanical dog walking and there's this
random dude who just kicks it but it
catches its balance
i've always wanted to do some sort of
video around
this concept these humanoid robots that
are just getting kicked
by scientists and whatnot and we got
this motion capture suit from xsens and
all of a sudden
bam the idea hit boston dynamics video
with the xs suit about
scientists trying to test the robots but
also
kick them and beat them with hockey
sticks all sorts of inconveniences that
eventually result in the robot turning
on the scientists
in some goofy way actually the hard
part's over
now we're at the easy part where we're
just doing a quickie oh background
paint out wrong the motion capture stuff
that ended up being really easy
all the clean place stuff that we
thought was gonna be easy ended up being
the hardest part to rewind all of this a
little bit let's explain what it is
we're doing
have you ever seen the movie chappie by
niall bleemkamp
pretty good new bloomf chappy the way
they
approached making that movie was
basically have charlize
carplosi he wore the xson suit the exact
same suit
that we borrowed and made the
transformers video with they basically
just had him
acting out the scene as the robot
chappie so it's actually the real actor
charlton copley in
every single shot of the movie and then
what they do is in post they basically
just
erase him from the shot and composite in
the motion captured
robot the advantage to doing that is it
gives the other real actors in the scene
someone to react
off of that gives a more honest
performance from the actors and it makes
it
so good i mean usually those big budget
big boy movies they got a lot of big
boys on those things you know hey
christian can you print out the credits
for chappie i mean how big do you think
the vfx team was on chappie
like 30 people 40 credits for the movie
visual effects and special there's like
50 people
i don't know oh
it's the entire team not including
animators but i figured this would be
enough for what you guys wanted so
wait a minute including animators there
you go senior prep
artist technology lead onset data
wrangler
digital compositor research and
development visual effects artists
modeler
lighting supervisors
research and development positives
what they wanted if we can just split up
these jobs
so circle all the jobs that you think
you can handle for this uh i'm gonna
take pages two
through five here look i'll go from here
i'll just draw a line through the
sand what are you doing this is not a
time to goof around dude
look at all this work we have look at
all this work all right so why did we go
through that whole little exercise
other than to point out the fact that
we're basically doing hundreds of
people's worth of jobs
between the two of us obviously chappie
has hundreds of vfx shots and they just
need
lots of people working on it in order to
do everything in the time allotted yes
but the other thing is that each one of
those people are specialized
chew chew keep chewing
what's your fortune what does your
fortune say
you have a vibrant personality no way
that's what it says
it's a hot day today i want to be able
to go outside get some fresh air and
move around so throughout the day
periodically i'll go and take like a 10
minute one wheel ride i have to limit it
to 10 minutes because
in the middle of summer in los angeles
it gets pretty hot out it's like 92
degrees out right now and i know
where you're watching this from it might
be hotter grown
they actually sent us a couple things
today from their commuter
selection we're going to put these
through a test by actually
going out in that 90 degree weather in
los angeles for a one wheel ride nick
and i are both gonna go because nick
also has a one wheel now
these are meant to be worn like to the
office supposed to be really comfortable
casual wear but you can also
sweat in it and no one will ever notice
we're gonna test them out
and see how they perform so ron is a
men's lifestyle
premium clothing brand and they make
stuff with like high quality designs
high quality materials it's all really
well engineered together
and it fits really well they make all
kinds of things such as like shorts
t-shirts tank tops swimwear
socks even it's kind of like the
performance alternative to
regular everyday clothes breathable
it is a little hot out today i'm tempted
to roll my sleeves up but no
these clothes are so nice and breathable
dude can we just take a moment to
appreciate that nick is filming on a
onewheel right now
check this out
i'm doing it
so all you got to do is go to roan.com
quarter crew and use the promo code cord
or crew to get 20
off your first purchase it's great
should we head back now yep you gotta
get back to work man
you don't even have pit stains razor
pits dude oh my god you're right i'm
gonna straight up say i recommend these
shirts i think they're great
all right so in the world of visual
effects there are literally dozens if
not hundreds of individual steps to take
you from i have an idea
to basically delivering something that's
finished i wanted to break it down step
by step
without going into too much technical
detail that'll make you just snore your
your eyelids off your face now obviously
before we can actually proceed with
making this video we need a 3d model of
a robot that can be rigged
to our motion capture suit and that's
where clint comes in take it away clint
what's up guys we don't have time to
build the robot so we downloaded a robot
and it looks like this
just a gray old robot first off we have
to match the colors
of the real boston dynamics robot to
this cg robot
what i'm looking at here is how
reflective is this chest plate
same for the rubber i'm looking at these
reference images
and translating it to cinema 4d once
i've textured atlas and i've got all my
colors in the right place i got all my
rubber my metal my chrome my plastic
we got carbon fiber carbon fiber thighs
that is the strongest material
super strong and it is destructible
carbon fiber is indestructible ran how
many times do i
how are we going back to anyway i gotta
weather the robot
it looks too clean my wacom tablet
there's scratches
all over the top of this thing right you
can see it's weathered it's not
perfectly clean it's not out the box
just like this robot i want to make this
thing look dirty because this thing has
been abused
dirt texture on it it's got you can see
the fingerprints here scrapes
some scraps all that good stuff last
thing i need to do before i kick it back
to ren
separate all of the limbs i have to move
the anchor point of those pieces right
in the center
of the joint so that when the elbow
bends the elbow is bending from
somewhere
somewhere in here the 3d robot will move
exactly as my body moved driven by
the motion capture data now that we have
our robot ready to go we can connect it
to our motion capture data
in our actual scene all right our
loading dock here to the building is
where we filmed this whole video and in
order to make the motion capture suit
actually work you have to have it in the
correct space in 3d
the entire idea here is that we're
trying to recreate exactly what our set
was in real life
digitally so that way we can actually
place the camera exactly where it was in
real life and also clint's
motion capture data exactly where it was
in real life so now that we have a
digital set and we have our track camera
and a synchronized robot the shot is
essentially ready to render
except that we don't have any lighting
yet and that's where the hdri comes in
so using an insta360 camera i was able
to take several different 360 photos at
different exposures
and i merged them together in photoshop
to make one high dynamic range
image why is that important what allows
me to basically take the real lighting
of the scene
to influence the 3d model and it looks
pretty good once the lighting is set
we can now render the shot this is where
people commonly refer to render times
because this is where it starts taking a
lot of time
all that 3d stuff is the fun part now
comes the compositing which can be
considerably less fun sometimes
especially on a project like this
it's the compositing that's been taking
so much of our energy so the first step
is to erase clint from the shot
you have to create what's called a clean
plate now clean plates are incredibly
easy to do if you don't have a moving
camera if your camera is moving around
on a tripod it's a little bit more
challenging but not super hard
it's essentially like a jigsaw puzzle of
different freeze frames of different
empty images
so this is what that looks like clint's
been removed from the shot but so have i
and so has jake we're all just
completely gone from the shot so the
trick here is now bring us back
so now we're at a point where clint's
been removed from the shot and
everything that needs to remain in the
scene has been put back in
that brings up one very important
challenge that this video has taught us
never put anything absolutely nothing
behind clint because clint and the robot
are not
the same size and because the
proportions don't match up exactly we
have to remove clint but the problem is
that anytime anything is occluded
by clint we have to now recreate that
check out this
part right here so i'm stepping here and
clint's foot you can see is directly
in front of my leg here how do you paint
out a moving leg the answer is you don't
you recreate it from scratch using
different bits
of the leg from other moments in the
shot that's an actual composition
of multiple different parts of my feet
so now this is the final shot
that's one example of probably about a
dozen different times throughout the
course of this video where we had to
recreate
different parts that had to be erased
and then brought back into the shot
which brings me to the most intense
moment of the entire video that had to
be erased
which is something that we thought was
an amazing idea on set
that in hindsight turned out to not be
the best idea and that was having a
practical light on set
to recreate a muzzle flash now we have
this light
that's really cool for creating muzzle
flashes on set because then you get the
realistic
actual lighting that you would get from
a muzzle flash just from off screen with
a little
fl he's already pointed up at the
ceiling and yet there's still no light
boom there's the light he's pointing at
the ceiling when the actual light goes
off that's out of sync with the actual
gunshot that we're gonna have to
composite
in but that's only one of the two
problems the other problem is that we
have a clean plate
a racing that doesn't actually have
the lighting of the scene
suddenly there's no light in the scene
at all now i have to actually
create a muzzle flash light in the scene
so i actually went back into cinema 4d
and opened up the project file for this
shot and i placed the light right in
front of the robot
to capture the shadow from that light it
looks like there's an actual gunshot
going off for that frame now
now we know not to do that in the future
just add that to the list of the dozens
of things we've learned
while making this video and once all
those steps have been done
once everything has been finished you
want to watch it all
and then critique it over and over and
over again we're our own harshest
critics you guys think you can be pretty
harsh with how our visual effects are
that's nothing compared to how harsh we
are on each other clint is the worst
visual effects artist
i've ever met in my entire life what did
you say nothing i didn't say anything
you do this cost
benefit analysis when you're doing this
polish review because you're like okay
this is something that i can fix but do
i have enough time to fix it is it worth
spending that time to fix it a lot of
the times it's not worth it once you've
gotten to that point
and then you can hit render from your
compositing package
and put it into your edits then you are
done doing the effect
and then you can sit back and watch all
the comments tell you about how bad of a
vfx arts you are and just cry into your
pillow at night
at the end of the day i just want you to
think it's a fun video i just want you
to be entertained we're not perfect
artists
but we're decent you know and we're
trying hard
assuming everything went right the video
is out right now and you can actually
click the link in the description
there's probably some sort of end card
at the end of the video you're watching
right now and it's going to auto play
right into that so just stick around to
the end
and keep watching to watch this boston
dynamics video
that we've made